whenever you think about the highest
paying jobs in the world you probably
think of CEOs or Hollywood actors the
you guys make tens of millions of
dollars a year and really the only way
to surpass their incomes would be a star
your own business but there's actually a
job that pays much higher than these
which is being a hedge fund manager that
top hedge fund managers in the world
actually make several billion dollars a
year but a high-level hedge fund
managers still often makes hundreds of
millions dollars a year but the top 25
hedge fund managers averaging six
hundred and fifteen million dollars in
granted these guys are the 25 best hedge
fund managers in the world but the point
still holds as they make far more than
the top fortune 500 CEOs who didn't
create their company for instance Tim
Cook made fifteen point seven million
Satya Nadella
earned forty two point nine million
Jamie Dimon made thirty one point five
million and so on and so forth the only
CEO that even comes close to hedge fund
managers is sundar Pichai who makes over
two hundred million dollars a year so
what the hedge fund managers even do and
why are they paid so much but before we
jump into that let's get a better
understanding of what a hedge fund
actually is so a hedge fund is simply a
pull of money that has been created
using contributions from several wealthy
investors and/or institutions this pull
money is then invested by the hedge fund
manager and his team into various assets
to try to make a return
the reason these pools of money are
called hedge funds is that originally
hedge funds would be structured in a way
to hold both long term and short term
investments this way investors are
hedged to reduce risk in other words
even if the long term investments
performed poorly the short term
investments could provide a return and
vice-versa as average people also have a
similar option to invest in which are
mutual funds the premise of mutual funds
is nearly identical except they don't
have minimum salary and net worth
requirements for investors like hedge
funds do so basically hedge funds are
just mutual funds for rich people
but the barrier for entry into the
average hedge fund isn't too extreme
generally hedge funds were required
income of 200 to 300 thousand dollars
with a net worth of at least 1 million
dollars while a lofty requirement with
the right job and good saving and
investment habits it's not too far off
for the average person however the top
hedge funds are only accessible to a
handful of people along with big
institutions taking a look at
Bridgewater associates which is the
largest hedge fund in the world with 160
billion dollars in assets under
management led by the famous Ray Dalio
requires investors to have at least 7.5
billion dollars and investable assets to
participate in the fund
so clearly top hedge funds take in tens
of billions of dollars but how much of
this actually goes a hedge fund managers
well the general rule for hedge fund
managers is a standard two-and-twenty
this means that hedge fund managers get
2% of a net worth of the assets per year
along with 20% of the returns that
produce above a certain threshold you
can see how this could lead to a lot of
money very quickly even if you're
controlling a small hedge fund of a
hundred million dollars just by meeting
the return threshold you'll be making 2
million dollars a year if you move up to
managing a mid-level fund of a few
hundred million dollars or a few billion
you'd be making 10 to 30 million dollars
a year which is the average amount top
CEOs make and though it's hard to become
a hedge fund manager it is significantly
easier than becoming a CEO there are
only 500 fortune 500 CEOs in the world
but there are 10,000 to 15,000 hedge
funds to manage as a result being a
hedge fund manager is much more
attainable than many other top paying
jobs so how exactly does one even go
about becoming a hedge fund manager well
if you have some sort of a large-scale
reputation a financial world you can
open your own hedge fund but that would
be opening in business rather than
getting a job so if you pursuit the job
pathway you would probably start off
with a degree in finance or a reputable
College followed up by a couple of years
of experience as a finance
analyst given good performance you can
generally land a job as a hedge fund
analyst in your late 20s which already
pays $175,000 with the five to seven
years of experience you can jump up to
being a senior analyst and make 500,000
to 1 million dollars a year and finally
with 7 to 10 years of experience as a
senior analyst you can usually become a
portfolio manager who makes several
million dollars a year this is the only
job in the world that allows you to
start off with a college degree and
quite reasonably work your way up to
millions of dollars a year by the time
you're 50
with that being said aside from the
money this is a pretty terrible job
hedge fund managers generally work at
least 70 hours a week and as you're
working off the corporate ladder he'll
often find yourself working over 90
hours not only are the hours extremely
long but the hours will be extremely
stressful as well the financial industry
is one of the most stressful industries
as you can imagine given the large
amounts of money and high levels of
return they're targeting but that's just
a reality of any high paying job and
that's why hedge fund managers make so
much if you thought this video explained
how hedge funds work well then make sure
to drop a like and consider subscribing
in fact the more questions just like
this one logically answered but until
then I'm Hari I'll see you guys on the
next one
[Music]